these are not judgments these are tips
now i feel like it was kind of a
judgment after you said it's not a
judgment
you know i didn't feel like it until you
said it okay okay well he [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
okay so brows this is actually the
beginning of the episode okay we just
had a super solid 25 minutes i didn't i
didn't press
jesus bro dude i hit a hard freestyle
that was like crazy yeah
he broke out in the middle of whatever
yeah
yeah i don't know if i could throw this
properly i'm so sorry about this oh
feel free to pull that mic uh up next to
your mouth as close as you want make
that thing your [ __ ] oh yeah yeah uh
someone smells good that thing yeah yeah
that thing's pretty [ __ ] up did you do
what did you try to do
i don't think it's me you
then if it's not if it's not maybe the
peach lotion i bought from my friend oh
okay oh okay
yeah that piece
i love that you said someone smells good
and automatically brows was like oh it's
not me it's not well he was looking
directly at me because you you you're
the new body in the room
it's either you're right
yeah one of you smell nice well thank
you yeah i think yeah hey
definitely put on girl lotion before
that's that's
fine that's the trick you put on girl
lotion so you can yeah
that makes me feel better like i was
like suddenly turned on when you guys
walked in
i didn't know why
anyways let's talk talent is so
attractive let's talk about it let's
[ __ ] talk about it i'm not scared of
magic mine no more really i'm a new
[ __ ] guy
so this is like two times in you drank
it last week uh yeah i checked it last
week the week before you know what i
felt great
dialed in because i think nick has some
[ __ ] directions
i didn't that was that was one part that
i'm glad we lost
that was that was slow
hey that's all fair
you know uh were you reading off the
door
yeah i thought it would be quicker and
fun i don't know but we were talking
about ashwagandha you ever been there uh
i've had it before
you've never been to ashwagandha oh it's
a great place really he says it's
beautiful this time of year yeah yeah
yeah hey we've been right
ashwagandha in images and you'll see
like how beautiful the [ __ ] is it i
really don't think the last time
chappelle was there he was drinking wild
turkeys yeah
take everything he says about it with a
grain of salt
i've actually been thinking about
adopting some ashwagandha
[Laughter]
yeah see why does everyone get confused
because
you think the s yeah that's what we're
like
i took away the [ __ ] cats i kept the
k kept the a in the d
yeah
you see what i did there that's how it
is neil degrasse tyson when you [ __ ]
i kind of want a sign
and it's just cats
i would love to have a sign that's just
like scratch this off like cats like and
tear that like terrible brown paper you
used to draw on in like elementary
school okay when you had a low budget
and it's just like red marker
that's really funny because i actually
just got approval from brenda to
actually get a sign made but that's
pretty funny
so after like all the design all the
contests we just go with braille
[Laughter]
what's up guys we're cats after dawg and
we're bringing you behind the scenes
stuff from all thing boy network and uh
other stuff a bunch of other stuff bro
you maybe you know you know what i felt
like i was doing hi i'm johnny knox
do you want to prep read on the magic
mind read we got a little tradition okay
we uh
so this is the sponsor right yeah yeah
we're sponsored by magic mind and what
does it do i don't know what it does uh
it's a it's a it's a focused drink
anti-procrastination is a small amount
of caffeine with matcha to have steady
focus throughout the day wow you're not
wired you're dialed in yes that's the
main point and everybody can get it
who's listening to this or you i'll get
you something for free
from ashwagandha
originally yeah
magicmind.com use promo code dark for
twenty five percent off
cheers cheers cheers
cheers
the only time i just kept
oh wow
honestly it grows on you
it does get back like the more you drink
it the better it does taste that's the
matcha flavor and that does have like an
acquired taste but like i now like it
because yeah starbucks i love this taste
yeah yeah because i drink a lot of
matcha so like
in fact yeah i know some white people
yeah
that's fair that's fair do more stress
buddy
he was like sensing we were in calabasas
pulling up he goes he like looked up
from his twitch and he's like from his
switch and he's like are we in calabasas
i'm like yeah he's like good i'm too
black to be here
immediately i
station and it was bad it was bad it was
too nice it did it didn't feel like what
i was used to like bro the gas price is
just [ __ ] high it's crazy yeah what
are y'all doing over here not a bathroom
without a code yeah
you
[Laughter]
you're like but i haven't bought
anything
you know the key with a broom sticker
right now
yeah just chilling just drinking some
magic mine feeling better now you feel
better i feel good i feel like i feel
you know i feel very
yeah i feel very alert did your
tolerance build up to it yeah i think so
yeah you know i you know i think it was
anxiety yeah
[Laughter]
you were anxious over some green tea
over some green tea i was [ __ ]
stressing out hard i was like brothers
about make my heart rate go up i'm about
to [ __ ] freak out
that's me with every [ __ ] thing
you're sweating for no reason on camera
gosh if i'm sick and i need nyquil oh
gosh i'm freaking out
i'm freaking out overnight i've never
really taken any night quilt one time
don't take it one time i took a tylenol
pm at like 2 00 p.m uh that's crazy i'm
thinking i was gonna go out yeah uh i
didn't i didn't know and like i woke up
at 11 like groggy like trying to move
like it was like when uh
scott gets hit with a dart in old school
uh yeah he's just like you're [ __ ]
crazy
right there where is he by the way huh
uh can we get him on
probably i don't think that's out of the
realm of possibilities at all everybody
tweet at sean williams scott yeah let's
get sean william scott on here right
stop playing i used to do that too nick
when i was a kid i didn't realize it was
because i was like kind of getting high
but i would take nyquil and try to stay
awake because i like the like loopy
feeling
afterwards and i didn't know what was
happening i was just like dude i can't
wait to be sick i'm gonna have a great
[ __ ] time i'll take nikola and stay
up i just thought of something yeah
because we were talking about uh
euphoria mm-hmm american pie or euphoria
in what regard like overall or they're
two different vibes it's hard to like
pick that's like it's hard to compare
high school once high school like feel
good [ __ ] the other one's drugs and like
[ __ ] murderers they're both kind of
raunchy but one is definitely darker
than the other i like american pie i
don't i you're you're more american i
felt last time you were here i was
sitting behind there that's also part of
the reason for three people on the couch
so like we have guests i can't yeah
barstow has this philosophy that like
the crowd the more crowded you are like
the more like loose people get which i i
like but uh when we were talking i i
but i felt very disconnected but we were
talking about euphoria and you're like
oh it's good that people see that
i didn't get in i hate how it just like
they make it feel like that's what
everybody's doing and if you're not
doing that then you're not a normal high
schooler so i feel like there's almost
like a i don't know there's something
but then again american pie was stifler
dude we're talking all those girls he's
still out there doing it's like 35 still
in college so i don't know if that's
that's better true i mean who's the guy
that hooked up with stifler's mom oh my
god [ __ ]
oh yeah that was the dude i was like
damn i want to hook up with an older
woman you want to hook up with jennifer
coolidge who's your uh yeah
right jennifer coolidge
i love doing that one movie with [ __ ]
hilary duff
oh cinderella story yeah you're not very
pretty yeah you're not very bright
yeah i [ __ ] love that people [ __ ]
love that movie
you listen to wale at all um yeah it's
dope yeah he ran for president of
nigeria i met him once actually that was
a weird day
i was super drunk and i've been at a
restaurant i think
everybody's got their own wallet
he's got a dope song
from like way back in the day what's it
called is there any love
is there any love
uh yeah it's wale and uh cuddy it's off
a kid named cuddy mixtape if you guys
didn't know i didn't know but i i do
love kid cuddy and wale but one of my
favorite songs by him is world tour and
he's like i'm he's like get high like
finch do mouse on american pi i can't
remember
yeah yeah yeah
with your chest come on there you go
i can't remember
nick did my podcast the other day and he
[ __ ] hey he knows his lyrics i spent
a couple absolutely he's like he's with
some kanye
kanye
was it all kanye uh the two i did tucson
two kanye
business oh no you did a little bit of
uh izzy
[Laughter]
you know is that one of your favorites
iggy
i'd say probably like top five yeah
but yeah who's she behind
um
just like who else is on the list just
like
kanye song kanye song iggy azalea okay
uh is that her name what's her name
right no but uh
we had a little discussion about iggy
yesterday and i said i didn't like music
yeah you know i know she doesn't come
after me for that because i i don't know
i mean it would all doers
whispers perspectives
i think the nicest way she's been told
that someone doesn't like her music she
went through a few years where people
did nothing but [ __ ] bashers yeah she
was so she was
yeah she was super popular around the
time she released that song fancy and
then shortly after that there was like a
hate train of like [ __ ] i love iggy
azalea bro that's just tight did you
guys give me all her albums
i think the breakfast club and then
someone called in
are you sure yeah that's a fake video i
don't that's a fake video but it
[Music]
and she was uh freestyling and what does
she do stewie is in philly what you want
to say stewie
this is that iggy that's crazy yeah i
just realized that
oh we were quick sean right
is that not the infamous john from
tennessee
that's iggy that's exactly yeah he's on
that
[Music]
christian this time it's definitely
coming out of the tv yeah
it's all good it's over all this will go
to the wow
slowest yeah the smoothest fast yeah we
want we want the wham i want freestyle
the best part about it is the subtitles
sometimes
i know it's so bizarre like it's a weird
thing i'm like seeing christians do this
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] get out of
everything you're doing now
and i've been relaxed the whole time
about it but i just wanted i want to be
behind the wheel
i think this is a great jump it over
right now to let go of
[Laughter]
she was at like uh some sort of festival
i think right
oh
[Music]
i'm going back and forth from reading
and listening
i can't tell what you're saying
it's it's actually hard though
does anyone know what she's actually
saying though yeah read the captions
she's actually saying that though
my favorite thing about it is that like
the crowd's going off
you know
good [ __ ] god in hell yeah well he's
not in hell but you know what i'm
talking about you know what i'm trying
to say yeah you know where i'm going
okay he's somewhere those [ __ ]
have no clue what the [ __ ] she just did
like
wait what think about because when jada
kissed freestyle on the verses against
uh
[ __ ] uh dipset it was like everybody
[ __ ] knew what was up right i have
never seen an episode of versus uh
there's there's some that i really like
i i really liked uh some of the magic
they're like d-max and snoop dogg's
[ __ ] phenomenal
yeah there you go
hey
i have an unpopular opinion on the iggy
i think that was actually hard i think
those were bars but like you know like
the audio like makes it so like muffled
alive that just sounds like everybody
but she was actually like that's her
dancer prancer like she was kind of
going in i i agree and like the oh yeah
are y'all agree now
[Music]
do you look her up on spotify no yeah
exactly [ __ ]
have you ever heard
yes yeah i like your addition better
never heard
a [ __ ]
you know wrong
that's the exact lyrics like the no
wrong that's another nick's cover yeah
i'm not i don't want to do it okay yeah
no yeah i'll only do that on
cameo i don't have a cameo set up yeah
or dude if you think that on camera or
patreon if you did that on cameo you
would blow the [ __ ] up like yo this is
[ __ ] dude
yeah yeah he looks like a [ __ ] wolf
and a vampire he'll [ __ ] it's crazy i
have an iggy [ __ ] for you to hug for
12.
yeah
it's so interesting
it's like one of the most expensive
cameos
cameos are so interesting i found that
there is a wave or there was a wave of
really hot girls going on cameo because
they didn't want the stigma of only fans
so they would make cameos for like crazy
amounts of money but they are doing it
all in like lingerie
and so it was like hi bob
i just want to say happy birthday like
just do it on only fans they take less
of it exactly because cameo takes like
30 of whatever it is
yeah that's what i was told whereas only
fans takes 20. i can never do cameo
i've been asked you've been asked yes
and you said no
yeah yeah you know i don't wanna i don't
want you to pay for me to [ __ ] say
happy birthday to you
like people have hit me up online before
like yo
my [ __ ] boyfriend's birthday he's a
big fan or whatever uh can i can i get a
shout out i was like just do it yeah i
don't give a zero would you do it if it
was like roasting them though because
you would do it like no i don't like
roasting anybody because i'm [ __ ] i
don't know how to roast anybody oh yeah
hey you ugly [ __ ] that's all i got
the right christian yeah
speaking of roasting who's the creative
force between behind uh flatlined with
david lucas
who produces that christian no one in
this room huh mike because they should
do that man on the street instead of
having people zoom in he should be like
they should have a sign be like on
hollywood boulevard we'll give you five
dollars to roast you and then he does it
to strangers instead of people who call
in yeah i was gonna say if it's him
walking around i think that might be too
much walking for david
the walk of david i said i said if he
was having david walk around and do it i
was going to say that might be a little
too much walking for david so maybe not
just all right
we're going to shut up i was david was
here to defend himself he would destroy
you oh i was just thinking i know right
no i'm sending him that yeah yeah
oh this is clips next week next week
we're going to get a response from david
yeah we're going to get a response from
david see what he thinks of me
that was my response to him saying that
i was wearing parachute pants the last
time i saw him like six months ago it
took me that long to come up with a road
trip i love that you just held on to
that one insult yeah you remember that
time you tried to pitch us your middle
miller light commercial oh man and then
none of it got recorded oh no
yeah hey hey maybe hey maybe that was
god saying yeah maybe you got to hold on
to it yeah you gotta hold on to it maybe
you can tell it that's right you should
still pitch us something next week i
feel like i got other commercials on my
thing i can pitch next oh absolutely do
you really yeah dude i used to do it all
the time like in height like not high
school in college when i was taking
classes i have like dominoes
uh miller like it's just all these
dunkin donuts uh suggestion for your
treatments don't use times new roman
found did i yes use comic sans
or wingdings
uh but um what's he gonna say oh uh next
time we do meatball pitches his
commercial or whatever we're gonna call
this segment it'll be in the middle to
second half of the episode
we're so shitty we tried to make it like
it was shark tank
like i was [ __ ] marcus and nobody
knew who lori was for the longest time
yeah and but then we know she's hot yeah
she's hot laurie's hot pull up laurie
what's she doing now
can we get her on yeah she's still good
times 40 minutes ago
[Laughter]
no i don't think it's like that oh go
ahead go ahead do what you do
yeah that's her
yeah
oh nice yeah first one yes there's
something like sexy about her oh yeah i
remember her anytime
we're trying to like we're like oh she's
attractive you just gotta go go like
lori shark tank hot yeah
and then
that's one of the tricks that's a great
headshot
and barbara barbara got them good teeth
yeah
oh damn what's up laurie there's your
bob yeah not bad she's cute
who's this
oh that's different girl yeah
that's her is it bro my favorite thing
about shark tank yeah i can't see like
obviously like obviously it's dope when
people win but i love when people come
on with their shitty [ __ ] products
that's not her shitty [ __ ] pictures
and their lack of making any money and
they're like hey man
i think i got this
i like what they look crazy they come
back and make tons of money like the
business actually blew up after that's
what i love that has happened you know
stevie was supposed to be on shark tank
and he agreed uh well before he got into
comedy he was
that'd be hilarious
before the like protein hype where
everyone was putting protein and [ __ ]
and making healthier versions of it he
actually pitched and had a patent for uh
protein ice cream
and he was uh gonna go on shark tank to
pitch it but then after doing a
background check they're like why is the
fbi investigating you we can't have you
on the show i don't know what you did
but we can't have you and then he got
injured
that ain't real don't believe what you
see on google
[Laughter]
so yeah he was always on shark tank damn
my friend was on shark tank really yeah
she so she did a company called crop
sticks
which is like bamboo chopsticks yeah
so they did the whole pitch
they didn't win or they didn't you know
get accepted or whatever but then now
they're killing it yeah everywhere yeah
oh really so it's good for a bunch of
restaurants disney even picked up their
crop sticks what a name i don't know
crop sticks i'm not sure
chopstick whatever crop
aren't you going to disneyland
i i already went
but i'm going again yeah how often do
you go to disneyland so you're right
at the end of the day you're right yeah
yeah i don't know you got this yes i
want to put it on the calendar right now
chin and i have been talking about this
for a while korean barbecue yes yeah
barbecue
what day in the next three weeks do we
have i love that you're putting this on
the spot so it's an actual thing because
this is the only way you're going to get
everyone to go while we're at it chin
did say he'd go with me and read too so
we might just join no i'm saying
everybody parties
i have so much guilt because ever
there's like everyone's like okay when
you go next time malka the team malcolm
they want to go i have to go with them
on thursday i think tomorrow mm-hmm i'm
gonna have a hundred they're like if i
don't invite you guys it's gonna be
weird i'm like okay let me just do it in
brackets you're going around all the
different tables
he's a friend with three different
friend groups that restaurant's like
this dude is lit he always goes with so
many
yes basically
well we couldn't film in there when we
tried to do that i didn't see that back
i don't think it came across how
tongue-in-cheek i was trying to be when
i said i experienced
it racism like i was really like upset i
semi think if i was korean they would
have let me in but i was not affected by
it
i was like i experienced it was weird
though it was weird they shouldn't yeah
yeah man you had me sitting here you
went home and cried about that [ __ ]
i man i was about to go comfort nick
when i was editing i was like this isn't
coming across right but i know i texted
him that night like that was not okay
nick
i'm so sorry on behalf of auntie
i was gonna keep that private but i
appreciate you checking me i just think
it's important for me to get it out yeah
yeah
i need to take accountability how about
march 18th
march oh i'm not in town damn it
am i
march 18th is bro
yeah or even a tuesday what if we go on
a oh you always have to edit the
episodes [ __ ] yeah wednesdays that would
be like
is there a spot after like around here
there's no we're going to go we got to
go
have you ever had ace gogi and he
doesn't go to anything that's ace yeah
why because it's not as good the the
meat quality's not as good he's very
bougie about his korean barbecue thank
god i was gonna say you gotta like try
it at least i've been in many ace i
still enjoy him a lot but if you guys
want to have real legit good amazing
yeah barbecue obviously
exactly nick oh yeah yeah
the ones that turned down
yeah
or quarters
if we can't get into either of those
other ones then we'll go to road to
seoul
there's still like the lowering out of
the background in my backup plan to back
up my backup please
[Music]
hey [ __ ] that what was she saying yeah
you said that [ __ ] was tight i just said
it i don't think okay i think it was
better than what it seemed like yeah
it was just funny
definitely compensated for everything
else that was happening yeah the fact
that you just like committed to it you
know what next time i listen to that i'm
listening to my eyes closed please just
open mine
close my eyes i'm not going to look at
the [ __ ] caption that people made
yeah
i'ma [ __ ] listen that's what i'm a
[ __ ] dude and try to imagine it
imagine if it was in a different
language maybe it hits really hard like
if you thought like oh she's not
speaking english it's like german yeah
you'd be like wow this is [ __ ] hard
this is great yeah
i wonder what she said what'd she say
we'd have to listen without no no no no
no i don't know the whole thing i'm sure
she named all 12 uh reindeer
she was like
[Laughter]
so she really got like a shitload of
hate yeah cause she was really popular
and then that clip had circulated online
it's just how the internet goes if you
get popular enough and people widely
like you and the [ __ ] that you make
you're just like due for a terrible
spiral happened with jennifer lawrence
happened with chris pratt it happens
with everyone who gets to a certain
level of celebrities
yes oh yeah good example would i love
her
well it's just weird because i'm like i
don't think her music's like
bad it's just like i like like i don't i
don't know your style yeah it's not my
style but like i'm not going to sit here
and be like oh [ __ ] iggy
but that's what people sit around and do
that's kind of what happens that's why i
feel like it's better for people not to
get super popular or super famous
because you're almost inevitably going
to fall into that pipeline show me this
cory labelle or whatever cory love
are you talking about patty labelle who
is this girl right oh
[Music]
oh this is the big purr yeah was this
the one that booted off
no it's just dead quiet
[Music]
no one's making no it's not the one
listen it drives me crazy that there are
so many [ __ ] people on stage and they
don't have a microphone in their hands
existing i can understand that if they
had a [ __ ] choreographed routine you
got to bring them to literally [ __ ]
do it it's like hey can you not carry
energy as a [ __ ] single rapper
like it drives me crazy why 20 people on
[ __ ] stage yeah it's like that's why
i like [ __ ] going to see like a band
cause it's like hey the guitarist is
going to do what the guitars does yeah
the bass player's going to do the bass
player drummer singer they're going to
do what the [ __ ] they do but these
[ __ ]
your friends
[ __ ] them yeah what are they doing bring
your own [ __ ] energy as a [ __ ]
art a solo artist to where you can just
[ __ ] it doesn't or or make them or
make the [ __ ] do some dances
hold on
y'all better come up with a [ __ ]
dance routine to help this [ __ ] out but
if you don't do that eat a dick and get
off stage sorry that was aggressive you
know when like it's like there's this
many people in the crowd and there's
that many people on stage and it's like
symmetrical
yeah it's like what am i watching
what am i [ __ ] watching the crowd
listen i've been quiet dude
i once saw jay-z
he was the only person on stage the
whole [ __ ] time
oh yeah just him
bro he didn't even have his band shown
they were like it was like weird they
were like kind of like low to the ground
like he had like this circle stage but
like he had like
space between space between uh but uh he
had that i almost did the same thing
but the band was like down and just so
like the band's right here jay-z is up
here right
he can't he carried the whole [ __ ] an
hour's set
oh yourself it's so much more
dope when like all eyes on you just
everybody's locked in you're just on
stage you asked on chappelle's world i
don't know how many i've we plugged that
a lot but i think we lost like the first
four of those plots
please support my podcast please watch
it every thursday at 3 p.m anyways but
you asked all your guests favorite
concert they've ever ever been to and i
saw mac miller at a rap festival in
minneapolis it was rhyme sayer's
soundset and he was the only person on
stage and like it was just incredible
and i've always been very kind of like
leery of wrestling i think that's i
think i think those are the better
artists
when like especially when it comes to
hip-hop because it's like it's you
rapping the songs unless you have a
feature obviously but a rapper that can
carry the whole performance by
themselves
who was that that was me oh uh how was
that it was uh
a clip from chappelle's word that was
going to kill you because it was you
[ __ ] kids
already no i had them all caught for
tomorrow tight yeah give me these
singing [ __ ]
i
[Laughter]
snapback ivan diamond shut down shine
and monopod this [ __ ] again change the
climate hop in this pitch again change
gum
why do we not have nick on the album
it's not too late i think that's what
this is he's like low-key auditioning
right now why didn't you hit him i think
he did listen
you made it
i heard all that beyonce
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah oh you mean on the album yeah
although she names all of the reindeer
yeah tie your monks
she gotta start her boss with them
if it doesn't start with tire marks i
don't want it tired so wait
wait so okay
did she quit rapping no she still makes
music but i believe she makes music
independently now i don't know if she's
assigned to a record label any longer
yeah uh but she's still tired but she's
still doing it she's definitely still
sure she still has a [ __ ] fan base
she's definitely making more money than
she was before being off the label what
do you mean yeah you're doing great yeah
so exactly yeah so why are you playing
ps4 i know what are you doing what is
that i thought it was fun nintendo
switch don't do that
your pokemon came out
so i brought my two switches and one for
your girlfriends
[Music]
it's a little disconcerting
yeah just kidding
pokemon yeah yeah are you playing
pokemon yeah yeah pokemon came out like
a few days ago oh she says pikachu in
that freestyle there we go
the monastery with the tired monks yes
dancer prancer donner
can we make up our own lyrics i feel
like with the three of you guys and what
you guys heard you can actually decipher
what she said
yeah
no listen the only reason why brows is
being nice because he wants her to
feature on the thick boy outfit possibly
true but also
[Laughter]
she missed the deadline to submit what a
great second yeah that's true
what a perfect segue
all i'm saying i don't think it's tight
i'm just saying if we were in person it
might have sounded better
that's it
if the right person mixed it it's a lie
also that was multicam so you would
think they would have hey they're
probably delivering the multi-camera
only has one sound source how much
appellate on this it's multi-cam but
they only had one sound source
now iggy azalea was sitting right here
i'm like dude i love your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes she missed the deadline but how many
how many submissions do you get little
brows is doing contests for who
someone can be on the thick boy album he
wants to give the same opportunity that
uh king and sing gave him yeah exactly
and we got one slot open i think uh i
got like a hundred submissions there's
five that we picked
and uh that's another reason why i read
this is my producer reed aka the bass
god all day and uh he's gonna help us
pick so i think we got five submissions
to choose from we're gonna go down to
two and then
we're gonna listen to them
amongst yeah we're gonna listen to five
amongst us we're gonna narrow it down to
two and then we're gonna zoom those
fellows in and then put their two songs
up to and the fans will completely
select from two people right yeah yeah
do you have one do you because i bet you
have a favorite would you be
disappointed if like i tried not to
listen too crazy hard i just heard a
little samples of the best one but um
i i pulled it up and it just popped up
on that screen
have you just spent also hours doing
this
like listening these submissions like
that's a lot like yeah yeah and to give
everybody like the like due diligence
it's right yeah going through
submissions is is actually it's fun i i
enjoy i enjoy i enjoyed listening to the
submissions we did yesterday for sure
like because good or bad it's like it's
cool to see like people's like
like it'll be like oh man this is such a
good song but a bad mix oh this is such
a good mix but a bad song this is such a
good like you know it's like everybody
has potential it's really cool to see
like you know just different levels of
where people are at yeah because there
were some submissions that like some
people sent stuff in they already had
like a big fan base like yeah million
views and [ __ ] like that and we were
like we want to give someone that's like
more low-keyed with like good like a
hidden gem like really good but they
just didn't have the right person to mix
their records yeah and we didn't we
didn't give rita a ton of background
he's your producer and yeah
just
he makes he makes all the beasts he's a
genius
i wouldn't say that but i mean i i make
i basically
make all the beats i record uh you know
every once in a while throw a line or
two if he needs it normally he doesn't
uh brows has enough lines for all of us
in this room but yeah you know um i just
try to try to make everything sound good
as quickly as possible that's about it
and also you're you're freaking you are
like brown said you're a genius dude
whatever inside the studio brows like
all right can you make something sound a
little blow it up make it like
theatrical here didn't it and you just
start going at it going at it and later
on within a few minutes it's already
there we're like what
so we can just concentrate on just like
singing and rap or him rapping and it's
just beautiful it's like it's a video
game i used to do that as a kid just
playing with stuff and i got good at
street fighter the same way i did it
producing you just do it every day and
enjoy it yeah and it literally becomes
like remote control yeah that's that's
how i've explained like what christian's
doing and like just you're playing video
games yeah you bring up bring it up
clean i i was just thinking about this
there was a huge gap where i didn't
video it at all i said yep
[Laughter]
but uh urban and gap i loved editing in
high school like just on like imovie at
the computer and then i didn't for years
but like i was good at it like i
remember this one video i can't even
explain how but it like i actually got
in trouble for it because i was like
making fun of a teacher's son but like
it was like i had the tiger and it was
like a fitness program that our high
school was doing and this kid was just
like standing there in like the softest
dance and it was like
every every every beat like it went like
someone else that kid
that's good
so this is the first submission yeah
this is our first submission
looks a little sad i'm not going to lie
i don't know why some of these are kind
of long so we could just get the fill
for them and yeah let's get it yeah this
yeah yeah yeah so
if there's no one that starts off with
tire marks or tire monks
and i don't want to [ __ ] hear you
know i think we're gonna know that and
like honestly
if they're not
uh no
uh after we listen to him we get to then
you can make the switch no no i'm saying
can i unplug this so we can all hear the
oh there should be two chords uh was
there not one
i don't
see another one oh uh
out of the board
is there not one next to it that has two
that's
yeah you can unplug it from mine
tired marks tired sorry i'm sorry i love
that as the show goes on we're gonna
slowly see
christian become like a great producer i
know he's getting good man you're
learning very quickly on the spot and
photoshop is the best way that's the
best way it's awesome honestly like when
i was learning how to mix records the
first time i ever touched anything that
had to be like audio gear i was trying
to get a show for my bands back in the
day as a kid and they were like yeah you
just have to run sound at the show and i
was like but i've never done sound and
they're like yeah we just need somebody
to run the board i was like okay i can't
believe that you're just [ __ ] yeah
dude i swear to god it was the hardest
thing in the world
like the first band goes up there like
we can't hear anything i'm like oh my
god i don't know what to press they're
like i'll press every button on that
thing until i figured it out
all right and we could be like uh tough
critics too like if it's not good just
say it's not good oh but this is top
five right these top five i hope i hope
they're all good
i want us to like oh yeah i'll put our
opinions in also we will give time for
iggy to submit yeah we'll like send it
so this is
three days ago so yeah you have three
business days until the wednesday after
this airs
and that's it
we're not gonna give her any special
treatment
all right so this was submitted by josh
peterson
[Music]
what
[Music]
maybe i was meant to say
what's the world with us
[Music]
yeah yes he's a slight dodger
what do you think jen you're a
classically trained singer i'm not a
classical trainer i know
she's like nope
but i mean honestly i think
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that 40 second symphony
yeah what do you think i think he can
he's got like a good foundation
but for the
for the thick boy album
i think if he fine-tunes his his craft
like just keep learning how to sing
to get everything i felt like he's
saying in a good spot in the in his he
sounds like you say it like doctor like
but i i do think he needs to refine his
singing a little bit
yeah and also the vibe too but yeah the
the singing yeah he's got a good voice
but he's good he's good he's good good
foundation
all right who's this next person no
video nope i do feel like we're hurting
these people because we're hearing like
an iggy azalea level of acoustics
out of our speaker
but the people who are listening at home
[Laughter]
is that the name of the episode
tired monks oh that's perfect dude the
last two episodes have been the new
sponsor we don't have one this this
episode is yes it's tired monks
is perfect do you say tired bugs yes
tired monks that's what we've been
saying the whole time
i think she's saying yeah she's saying
that yeah tire marks how do you think
the other one is i'm going to cut that
part it's tired monkey yes
so wait who's this new person
i don't know where this is there's a
video with this one
oh this is brian
there is a video there's a video oh it
wouldn't let me download the video for
some reason you did like a lyric video
and everything
should probably
where is it yeah where's it at see
what's on youtube all right give me a
second who's the guy who sings the song
la la land bryce oh bryce vine yeah
that's what he sounds like it does sound
like that's funny that's a little
different vine is [ __ ] dope this is
clearly about to be fire
yeah i think it's pretty good yeah i i i
think you guys he was like on the show
before oh this was the guy who did cats
on the phone oh yeah that guy was
awesome he was great yeah about the
first guy just
saying right now he did it he is mo the
most brave so far because he did it just
literally no
no yeah zero i i heard no yeah i did
like that yeah
auto tune just straight up recording
um and that's tough
but if it's enjoyable
pre-recording it's probably really good
after yeah exactly
people really do read you could take him
and [ __ ] make him sound amazing
[Music]
hold on i'm trying to find the video i
have it you have it okay hey you got a
wee ball we can't see it though
yeah i know thanks
yeah i know
thank you for letting me see myself i
like that on the back it says thank you
for letting me be myself that's tight
turns
i saw him the other night oh yeah i saw
that i was trying to go i was almost i
almost went oh dude i wanted to cry oh
dude i wanted to go you go to a live
show music a lot i want to go more yeah
any chance i get i [ __ ] go turns out
so sick yeah you should have told me you
liked me
you know what i you know what i i kind
of want to do for uh chapel's world is
such
i kind of want i mean it's just so much
it's kind of it'd be kind of be hard to
do
with all like i mean trying to film [ __ ]
but i want to like
do like a vlog concert vlog like my
concert kind of vlog thing it'll be cool
i'll be telling you you just need one
camera would you really yeah yeah i
think that all you have to do is be like
brendan give me kyle
yeah that's really concert and then like
i was up in the pit dude fans were
recognizing me it was kind of crazy yeah
that's awesome man
you
i mean you got lean into it more you can
be he'll come like this public figure in
the punk community like which is type or
the music community
in general
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
does yeah
all right my pronouns are
punk grunge
all right this was submitted from brian
[Music]
everlasting
[Music]
i be watching cats for the laughs and
the current events and advice on
relationships
i'm sorry babe fireboy said he got a
contest and browsing this [ __ ]
to other artists that put their work in
but i need to keep my house only and now
you're talking parties
[Music]
[Music]
have
[Music]
this guy's legit dude i mean the way
it's produced is
is
[Music]
dude this guy's dope this guy's dope
[Music]
[Music]
his name is uh-oh 6-0 or 8-6-0
[Music]
he's dope he's i actually haven't seen
this one
yeah he reminds me of everlast yeah
definitely everlast feels for that yeah
nothing else
you know
whenever that says like this his
acoustic on joe rogan's podcast yeah it
reminds me that's what he reminds me of
youtube that song and we'll cut it off
type it go to um
youtube meatball
you know where that is
i want to say it's called nothing else
matters what that's not the song you're
thinking of yes bro how you going to
i didn't get that vibe from this song no
go back go back go back
gosh
nothing matters nothing man
just type it everlast music
how fast can you make a make a customer
what a truck
no no no no go
sorry i was thinking i was thinking a
different man i was thinking this band
called trick turner go to everything you
could type in everlasting sorry i was
waiting yes it's 30 minutes what it's
like your word can feel yeah what it's
like
much smoother
monday.com
but okay okay a couple things pause it
quick
get ad blocker
yeah
for youtube and you wouldn't you'd skip
that this is all like these are not
judgments these are tips
now i feel like it was kind of a
judgment after you said it's not a
judgment
you know i didn't feel like it until you
said it okay okay well he [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
but
instead of like pausing it when we're
done like on your slider on the audio
just like bring it down we might be able
to leave it in uh and then uh look up
big boy tremendous damage big boy is so
fire
and underrated
danny kane has a song called damage
that's pretty good oh yeah that goes
hard my heart is damaged this one uh
the bridge of that song fire the second
one because they're like oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo what if nick was straight up like yo
this reminds me of the song i made
pull it up man real quick
like is that why i submitted this all
you were like
[Music]
so this was submitted by jeffrey milan
shout out to jeffrey malone
he's only audio yeah can we turn it up a
little bit can you get a little more
volume
that's as loud as it goes you get a
little more volume
you're [ __ ] people with your
criticisms
i'm just kidding how are you doing
like
what's your do you wake up you want to
kill yourself
oh yeah we like these melodies like
don't do it bro
it's cool yeah we're going to get
through this together me and you i
promise okay this is the biggest isn't
great
[Music]
hello
[Music]
just tell me what the business is
he was like four buttons away from being
right that's the sad part all right i
get the vibe yeah
yeah
jen you didn't you weren't following
that one not uh number two is still the
best for me right now yeah yeah 56
minutes cool perfect this that was so
that was jeffrey milan
dope track still
that's what it is
you can't change my mind but that was a
joke
he did a lot yeah
all right this is submission 4 by sabine
and his
ig doesn't have a rap name it's it's
bean boy
i think this was a singer oh b-boy
yeah it's a cover song i think he was
just saying if i had the videos i'd pull
him up
don't you think i'd be doing that
because it covers his art
[Music]
i feel like i'm watching an aspca
commercial or something like that for a
hook
that's what i'll say i'm listening for
his voice
[Music]
so i'm from lacrosse
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
he has a good voice
[Music]
uh
[Music]
that would be the funniest
[Music]
this was one of my favorites personally
[Music]
reid what do you think about this one i
think i think it's his tone is crazy
it's it's very light and nice i feel
like again it's it's like
it's the big movie hook you know what i
mean it's the like before eminem is
about to go on or like when somebody
does something really sad right before
it's like raining it's dark you know
what like the two cowboys finally figure
out they're gay
you know
yeah like this is the moment yeah here
they go pakistani
that's nico
damian that goes
yeah
but yeah huge decision to make standing
out looking over a cliff yeah [ __ ]
yeah
here they go two nuts broke back
mountain they about to get it yeah yeah
yes
i think we're free to do whatever we
want now that something please yeah
or like in the fugitive when he's about
to jump off that [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about oh yeah
one arm that's all i know that's the end
it's the end of titanic you know yeah
but yeah that was a sabino right was
that his artist's name yeah or beanboy i
think was his
emotional for a guy named beanboy yeah
does he go harder on the other track
this is the one time
off because i feel like beatboy is a
trap rapper right like that that sounds
like it sounds like a uk grime rapper it
sounds like you've done some illegal
somewhere and then this was submitted by
alex alex arthur or arthv ver is his rap
name aardvark
no not hard part okay it's a-r-t-h-v-r
so i don't know okay this is the dude
that went all out and did like a full
music video oh yeah
so he wrote arthur he used the v as a
youtube yeah yeah oh kind of like in
life oh so still art there or like
arthur there's an asap it's like a lot
of
people
let me pull up the video yeah dollar
sign dollar sign chase god lobby we're
not going to be able to hear half the
[ __ ] you say i love you i love your
contributions but sorry about that it's
all good the uh
player i'm playing the uh do you know
how to do it
no i don't oh okay
do a good meatball you guys you're doing
great
my mic at home is so sensitive i'm not
used to like having to be this close to
it this this would be terrible at my
house
this would be like
all of your speakers i
paid everything
oh my god what is he wearing i love him
already
so he did like a full music video
so it was respect for that
oh he got everything it's original yeah
he made it for the contest
okay i swear every time i watch this
video i feel like that it's that g-eazy
video and he put his head on somebody
else's head
you know what i'm talking about the g
easy videos
[Music]
you know what i noticed right now too
it's a cool song it's a cool vibe but
the references you make don't actually
do that
the beat is hard
to the studio
[Music]
is
[Music]
shout out to earth
it out everybody like say we were voting
for two people wait what are we where
are we going for our favorite the latin
your favorite too okay wait when what
are we doing
we're texting someone uh just like put
it in like a text box okay so we can't
cheat okay i'm up on my notes
yeah
well let's see wait so are we
i'm gonna
uh chabelle
what what are we talking about we have
to pick one winner oh two two my
favorite two and then those two are
going to be put up to a vote to the fans
who will decide who is that big boy
album mine's been changed their life
huh my two favorites are brian and
arthur
i don't know which what numbers
two and five two and
me five i was two and four
i love that
what was that
i was talking to him
everything okay
i don't know he's looking at me like he
wants to kiss me so i don't know eat a
dick
you guys read
me i i went two and three actually
two's in already he has like solidified
his spot
i went two and four two and four coming
for that number one
jen i feel recently biased but i did two
and five
two and five but everyone's got two in
there
yeah
i have
two and then it was close between three
and four i'm going to go ahead and say
four
so the cool kids i feel like we swayed
you so i told you what's in your text
box you didn't text
who am i supposed to text
you you just you put the numbers yeah
okay two and four
i was just see i remembered my people's
names
we also let you go my people
who are your people yeah they're
definitely not your christian people
two and five which is that
yeah we got we got a tie between four
and five
what do you mean
number two yeah yeah
yeah yeah that guy's dope uh he did that
cats on the phone song that also just
like great vibes yeah
he's dope uh
well
i get i guess we uh
[ __ ] how do we do it
um i like this producing on the fly
we're making it happen
so it's between four and five right now
uh to be in the last two with two should
we just listen to all three of them and
put them all back or should we just
listen as four and five once one more
time yeah one more time
you never don't know what i said the
reason c buy us like what i said i know
what i heard
i might retire more
whoa
entire marks if i heard that i would
have changed now now i'm going to start
following iggy and i'm a fan now we're
all [ __ ] up we're all [ __ ] it's 4 30
we should podcast for two more hours
we're going to be here like or in
traffic i got to get on i got to get on
a hike
yeah i got to edit two and five two and
five but there's no there's no rules
right do we have to settle down to or
we could we could do three top three
it's harder to do
oh okay but no there's other polls you
could do you could do you could link to
polls
it's his contest
i'm down with two and five they're both
great i think we should do two and five
i mean you should be deciding yeah you
should be the deciding factor yeah no
they were both dope and i feel like they
both be the head producer the whole
thing i'm just i'm just shout out to
four though man you're incredible yeah
no great voice yeah dude seriously great
voice i love that one that's what was
like sad to do it because it's so good
like oh man but at the same time
right i feel like i'm on american idol i
ain't gonna say [ __ ] i did two and five
you know what i feel i know what i
figured
i felt it you said what you said i said
let's get turn style on it i said what i
say and i know what i say because i said
it mm-hmm and you were right there's the
we they won
well they're in the the top yeah they're
right we'll see what happens also please
get mark you basically on the thick boy
oh yeah that'd be great you know because
when i think about back to the time when
i was at juilliard
oh yeah
back then when when were you there
he walked by at one time yeah when you
think about juilliard you think of
creativity you think of excellence and
you know that's what we carry
listen we can hear npr voice
and
his excellence when i think of brian and
arthur i think of juilliard so jesus
what about
just the excellence just the creativity
the scenery same thing
classically trained
the uh
you know it just
yeah
feeds the soul rejects it
that's definitely your playlist yeah
yeah your music's probably playing dude
dude
uh meatball i can't stop listening to
the uh mac miller song those
ones you showed me i don't know
which one
it's [ __ ] fire hold on i got you
oh it's just listening
programs
oh that's a banger
here we go
good evening thank you
one of them one of them
senior skipped it back when he was
stealing beats wait so uh
um so we'll we'll do a poll
yeah for two and five
and but uh we're also going to talk to
them both very quickly oh right now
right now oh shoot next week wait so
what happens to maybe we do it next week
and then we reveal it
okay yeah right
yeah
is everybody just waiting hopefully like
waiting for a text from you
next week yeah like the winner
or we can just just go next week
he's been here a while
he's been here about 11 a.m they get 30
seconds no i don't know whatever you
want to do it's 3 a.m i must be lonely
get my guitar with my guitar at meatball
i maybe we do it next week sure
but they're ready i don't know i'm torn
i'm i'm hurting people's feelings i
don't want to hurt people's feelings i
hate hurting people hey
hey [ __ ] me yeah
[Laughter]
wait is this part are we um
like what are we uh
hey if we do this zoom right now you
better get sean william scott here next
week then
also if we do only stipulation if we do
it next week we can possibly tell them
to like prepare something too to like
leave them off on like the fans
all right just like a little extra
something to
help them through they were all they
were all waiting like
yeah i think they'd be done by to do
tomorrow right next week
yeah yeah yeah next week but yes yeah
next week they all would everybody's
like grateful that they're being texted
by christian
which is a wild world we live in
so i gotta ask am i allowed to uh take a
picture behind that thing after we leave
[ __ ] yeah yeah well but don't don't post
it until actually after um
the episode
next no next thursday okay because this
is all new set okay yeah for sure oh
yeah yeah no good to know
yes sir oh we should all get a pic
well you take them a lot
oh very quick very quickly christian
bring up those results of the new logo
we have the results of our logo poll
and we have a new king of sting what's
this logo the first one
made by reuben oh that's ruben
this one yeah right here no this was
actually made by mikko serrano oh oh uh
i love amigos he's pretty good
he goes dope he has a ton of you guys
right
oh i actually do know yeah you met him
yeah i know that's why
but he does a ton of photoshops for king
of the sting he used to do flyers he
used to make your dates and he remember
when we would do like the rate my state
stuff like that he was a guy making all
those graphics yeah i you would die
coach nick
oh the top one was oh yeah the top one
top one yeah so
and if you like zoom in
these are the we had a competition on we
let the fans of the thick boy instagram
vote which logo they thought would be
better for us
and
the people have spoken
and the the top one is like you said
reuben uh what's his lesson ramos
raymond uh he's incredible he does so
much for the big boy
um he does this pro bono just shot one
out i bet he's like now probably fired
up and it will send another yeah but
yeah mikko won by a landslide 84 16.
because that that should still open
brian johnson's gonna make a sign the
top one's nice too it's so just classic
versus like the bottom ones
it's crazy i like that i really do like
they're both great two
two so that was my personal favorite
even though i do love reuben
i do
personally like the bottom one that's a
cool idea yeah i don't love you
i didn't ask if you called me i just
well you're saying
one i just had to get one something
meatball
dis
[Laughter]
we gotta get chappelle out of here and
on a hike his anger management right
he's [ __ ]
out the window right now yeah he's gonna
verbally berate meatball hey he talks
[ __ ] to me you see what he posted about
me today
yeah pull that up meatball because it's
actually pretty funny he said no i got
this one
nobody need help with this
pull it up and then i'll tell everyone
what someone said to me when they saw it
uh
he's like oh that's command shift 3.
[Laughter]
you go there
so all right so you see the picture so
that's the guy from the the actor from
hey
here's what someone said they go hey man
it's kind of nice of you to take
meatball skating
[Laughter]
sign us out oh yeah hey thanks for
listening uh every sunday we drop these
episodes at 8 30 p.m uh the the love has
been great the love is tight love is
real and um uh we'll do
we'll keep doing this because uh that's
what we do why don't i always have to
[ __ ] sign out because you're great at
it you're good at it you're right you're
right all right thank you guys
bye cats
[Music]
you